it's great to be here and it's great to
have so many of my sources
together in the same place I'm a little
uncomfortable in this role to
traditionally I am taking notes
listening to everyone else talk I am NOT
a scholar in any sense but i have had 20
years of experience writing about
Mormonism at the salt lake tribune so a
few years ago a new reporter in The
Associated Press's Salt Lake City Bureau
was assigned to cover LDS General
Conference I chuckled when I read his
report on the wire which said that then
church president gordon b hinckley had
been quote re elected unanimously quote
not wanting the reporter to be
embarrassed or have to write a
correction I called him to explain that
this was not any kind of election but he
persisted it as if I were accusing him
of not being there but I heard the man
stay all in favor raise your hand the
reporter told me and everybody did he
reluctantly altered the wording in his
account but did not seem to grasp the
Mormons unique practice of quote
sustaining their profit with a show of
hands as a symbolic gesture and I don't
really blame him Joseph Smith borrowed
the term general conference from the
Methodists but used it to mean a very
different kind of gathering I've been to
a Methodist general conference and it is
very much a voting body where
representatives from different local
churches and regions meet proposed
churchwide resolutions than discuss and
debate their merits my experience with
that reporter has stayed with me and has
come to exemplify the problems I see
facing well-meaning reporters who said
about to try to write fairly and
thoughtfully about the utah-based church
its theology practices and people after
watching journalists across the country
indeed the globe scurry to try to
explain presidential candidate Mitt
Romney through an understanding of his
faith I have concluded that they seem to
be using a Protestant prism that affects
their choice of tone perspectives
sources and doctrines to highlight
though the facts in any given story may
be essentially correct
phew Mormons recognize themselves in the
emerging picture that's because it's the
wrong model and it leads reporters to
ask the wrong questions and make the
wrong assumptions Romney may have some
personal power in the LDS Church because
of his prominence in family history for
example but he gets no special perks
from paying millions in tithing as some
writers presumed he cannot run for
church LDS Church President as a
Bloomberg writers speculated if he fails
at winning the presidency the church may
be against gambling but it wasn't going
to sanction the candidate for proposing
a ten-thousand-dollar bat with two rec
Perry so here's my list of top six
mistakes reporters make in the coverage
of Mormonism number one misunderstanding
or misusing Mormon vocabulary latter-day
saints have their own lexicon including
such unique terms as sacrament meeting
primary word of wisdom ward stake
general authority and so forth a little
aside on the general authority I had a
colleague at the paper came from
Hartford Connecticut absolutely not
religious in any way one of her first
assignments had to do with the higher
education she had an opportunity to
interview an apostle on the topic and at
the end she said what's your title what
should I put as your title and he said
I'm an apostle and she told me in her
head she she thought yeah and I'm the
Virgin Mary really who are you ah so
yeah the title thing is hard I can be
daunting to reporters trying to cover
the Fate sermons are talks communion is
the sacrament an all too frequent error
is dropping Jesus Christ out of the
church's formal name calling it instead
the Church of the latter-day saints Plus
here's another problem a dizzying number
of people in a given ward or stake are
called president how is a reporter too
well if an elders quorum president has
as authoritative opinion as a stake
president Mormons have different worship
services offices ritual scriptures and
history ah number two misusing common
vocabulary that means something
different to Mormons an LDS seminary is
not like training for the ministry
here's an interesting note ah that I
discovered on while in Brazil a
Brazilian law was passed required any
clergy person coming into the country
from outside to have theological
training so the LDS Church came up with
the plan that's you know it's
missionaries are considered clergy and
so only only missionaries who have our
seminary graduates will be called to
Brazil of course those are high school
classes but that seems to meet the law
an elder can be 19 a fifteen-year-old
boy can be a priest missionary serve for
a limited time not as a permanent
calling then there's all those terms
that Mormons using frequently if at all
Mormons don't typically talk about being
born again they don't use words like
piety or pastor or even really
denomination that's not a Mormon term
three number three misunderstanding the
relationship between LDS General
Authorities and leaders at the local
level the hierarchy is much more rigidly
set than the Vatican but leadership at
the local level is constantly rotating
again due to the church's unique
vocabulary a quote high priest seems
like well an important official to a
reporter Romney is a high priest having
served as a bishop and a stake president
but so is everyone else who served in an
LDS bishopric and most of the men from
middle age on up how could a reporter
decide whether a high priest is really
an important opinion to get number for
presuming an LDS bishop has this
empower and role as a Protestant
minister a Protestant minister Catholic
priest or megachurch pastor is at the
center of a congregation preaching
weekly and representing the views of his
or her adherence and the church a Mormon
Bishop is a volunteer with a separate
full-time job who is essentially an
administrator and counselor it doesn't
typically give sermons on current events
number five mistaking folk doctrines for
core beliefs this is especially obvious
in those writers who use the Book of
Mormon musical as their source on LDS
teachings the list of beliefs offered up
to a newspaper audience often seems
arbitrary and idiosyncratic it's not
surprising that Mormons don't see
themselves in these accounts all about
planets becoming gods and magic
underwear for most Mormons these are not
ideas that are often discussed at their
weekly services the church's health code
again is frequently miscast I personally
have called out Maureen Dowd in the New
York Times twice for saying that Mormons
don't drink caffeine and was much
gratified to see the paper of record
write a correction on it number six
treating all former Mormons as
whistleblowers who who promised to
reveal problems within the faith unknown
to outsiders this is a journalistic
model that may work in certain
institutions and for certain ethical or
moral lapses such as cases of abuse
former Mormons may and often do have
compelling personal narratives that
could and should be included in pieces
as long as they are balanced with
equally compelling stories of
satisfaction and conversion but not many
former Mormons are fair-minded observers
of the contemporary church during the
last five years I have watched an
avalanche of writing about Mormonism hit
the airwaves newspapers and blogging
world my inbox is awash with Mitt Romney
/ Mormon gurp Google Alerts nearly every
story written about them
and mentions that he is a Mormon the
word most immediately identified
associated with Mitt Romney is Mormon I
have been largely impressed by the work
of my colleagues on the religion writing
beat such as x Laurie Goodstein who was
here yesterday Kathy Grossman at USA
Today Rachel Zoll of The Associated
Press Adele banks and Daniel Burke of
religion news service and Dan Gill Gough
and Jessica Ravitz a former colleague of
mine at the Tribune who have worked
strenuously to understand and explain
this american-born faith some political
reporters at majors papers also have
spent a lot of time schooling themselves
in Mormonism but I have also been
astonished at the misrepresentations
biases absurdities and flat-out
hostility towards Romney's faith that
have found a voice on the editorial
pages of prestigious newspapers and
websites Joanna and I Hal over some of
the reports she calls them out often on
her blog and I quietly fume it has made
me deeply skeptical about my profession
so let me start there and work backwards
to the positive examples okay believing
the unbelievable this is a common thing
among among some writers talked about
Christopher Hitchens this morning in
2006 late writer jacob weisberg set the
tone that many others would follow into
2012 quote i wouldn't vote for someone
he wrote who truly believed in the
founding whoppers of Mormonism writing
in The New Yorker in 2008 political
commentator hedrick Hertzberg said quote
the dogmas of mitt romney sect are
breathtaking they include these and in
1827 a young man named Joseph Smith dug
up a set of gold plates covered with
indecipherable writing that with the
help of a pair of magic spectacles he
translated the plates from an otherwise
unknown language into Old English that
reads like an unfunny parody of the King
James Bible the excuse me the late
Christopher Hitchens decried what he
said was quote the weird and sinister
belief system of the
yes then came the really unexpected
harang by literary scholar harold bloom
against modern Mormonism in the new york
times when Hitchens called Mormon
founder joseph smith of fraud and a
conjurer bloom said he didn't go far
enough quote a suburb trickster and
protein personality Smith was a
religious genius uniquely able to craft
a story capable of turning a
self-invented faith into a people now as
numerous as the Jews broom bloom wrote
the last two decades have witnessed the
deliberate to win dling of the Church of
Jesus Christ of latter-day saints into
just one more Protestant sect bloom
condemns the current President Thomas s
Monson claiming he is quote
indistinguishable from the secular
plutocratic oligarchs who exercise power
in our supposed democracy bloom then
concluded by attacking both a Southern
Baptist and the Mormon speculating on
which would be more dangerous an
American president a knowledge hungry
religious zealot REE or a proudly stupid
one either way we are condemned to
remain a plutocracy and oligarchy I can
be I can be forgiven for dreading a
further strengthening of theocracy and
that powerful brew so who do reporters
turn to for experts the New York Times
and CNN seemed to have given a platform
to every former Mormon with a book on
several occasions the cable news show
interviewed Trisha Erickson described as
the author of the new book ken Mitt
Romney serve two masters the Mormon
Church versus the office of the
presidency of the United States of
America quote I cannot explain to you in
a few words here just how completely
violent mind controlling and alarming
these temple ceremonies are just this
information on the secret temple
ceremonies would send most thinking
humans beings into warning mode that
maybe we all better rethink who our
Republican candidates should be Ericsson
told CNN I can't stress enough to you
how truly alarming these ceremonies that
mitt and Ann repeatedly went through and
continue to go to and participate are
Erickson a self-styled whistleblower
said she was waiting for someone else to
expose the evils of Mormonism before
jumping in it just amazed me she said in
an interview knowing what I know that no
one else would expose what has to be
brought to light to the American people
about this candidate no one else has
exposed this really has she read the
internet whaley ah sounds very much like
the thesis of writer jon krakauer author
of under a banner of heaven who argued
that Mormon teachings lead inevitably to
violence another former Mormon Sally
Denton this week told the New York Times
that male dominance is the essence of
the LDS Church to be sure the church
patriarchy is a problem for many Mormon
women but Denton makes it the faith
central issue she then cites Sonia
Johnson a Mormon feminist who was
excommunicated from the church in 1980
that perspective is about three decades
behind the times much has changed in
those decades and it is astonishing that
she couldn't find more current feminists
to showcase the she then goes on to warn
the readers that given giving Romney the
presidency would be tantamount to
allowing the LDS Church's Church free
reign over the country an ill-informed
opinion at best a dangerous stereotype
at worst protesting the faith again
using a Protestant model some
journalists presume that if Romney or
any Mormon is displeased with his
church's direction he should public
publicly criticize the institution or
leave it for another after almost
mainline Protestants align with
congregations that share their political
perspective as well as their theological
views and if they are not satisfied they
can seek out another wing of the
denomination or switch to another
denomination within the umbrella of
historic Christianity but Mormonism is
more tribal than that even though they
might be upset by the Church's stance on
gays blacks or women most believing that
latter-day states say would stay with
the faith trying to change from within
thus Romney responded very typically in
2007 on
Meet the Press with Tim Russert um who
had noted that Romney was 31 when the
priesthood ban was lifted in 1978 quote
don't you think what am i doing part of
an organization that is viewed by many
as a racist organization Russert asked
romney replied i'm very proud of my
faith it's the face of faith of my
father's and I'm not going to distance
myself from my faith in any way I mean
that seems obviously to people who do
walk away from a church that they have
trouble with issues that seems normal
but in Mormonism Romney's response is
very normal just yesterday in
african-american website loop 21 pose
the question can Romney lead America if
Mormons hated blacks the site then
conducted an interview with Derrek
evensen an activist ex-mormon everyone
in this room knows that the LDS church's
history with blacks will be scrutinized
and analyzed during Romney's campaign as
it should be excuse me but as max
Mueller showed yesterday this is a
complicated history and should not be
reduced to its most egregious elements
it is not in Romney's personality or
upbringing to challenge LDS authorities
or criticize its history that is not the
Mormon way so use of language some
stories subtly suggest ulterior motives
about LDS practices considered consider
some of the initial stories about
Romney's tax returns Romney has sent
millions to the Mormon Church screamed
ABC News than we're not to say security
securities records show that Romney
found ways to help include the church in
some of the company's most lucrative
deals hint hint horrible under Scott
underscoring the prominent if little
discussed role that Mitt Romney played
as a Mormon leader the private equity
giant once run by the GOP presidential
frontrunner carved his church a slice of
several of its most
lucrative business deals as if he was
trying to hide his his most lucrative
business deals by giving tithing to the
church security security records show
providing with millions of dollars worth
of stock in some of bain Capital's most
well-known holdings the message is clear
Romney was doing something nefarious by
giving his church quote a slice of his
lucrative business deals subsequent well
anyway or how about this one from the
Christian Science Monitor quote the
strength of Romney's religious
conviction conviction now has a dollar
sign attached to it will his tithing
invigorate the unease that many
Americans feel towards the Mormon Church
subsequent stories did explain that
tithing is normal and he wasn't doing
anything of areas and lots of people
give stock to the church but the initial
stories out were sort of oh no this is
horrible even those who have genuine
insight about Mormonism such as American
historian David Reynolds
mischaracterized Romney as a Protestant
he had to be gently corrected by our own
Jana Reese in The Times discussion in an
October 2011 cover story for Harper's
pennies from heaven writer Chris Lehmann
put together her rang about Romney
supposed view of economics that called
Mormon teachings the Protestant ethic on
steroids and paid no attention to the
face communitarian strain of thinking
lehman assembled quotes from various
leaders conservative members and
scriptures to argue that Mormons believe
more than any other Christians in the
quote prosperity gospel a term has
mostly been applied to prot some
Protestant theology and one latter days
and it's one that Latter day Saints
would never use or even really recognize
suggesting that the accumulation of
wealth is a major goal for Mormons a
symbolic symbolic of God's favor Mormons
like Romney may be wealthy and many may
credit their successes in life to their
self-proclaimed righteousness but is not
a fair or insightful look at Mormon
economics in any way my fellow panelist
russell called it balderdash now now for
some good examples in november jason
horowitz of the Washington Post wrote an
excellent story about Romney's evolution
in his treatment of Mormon women when he
was a stick president Horowitz revisited
some of the episodes where Romney was
patronizing even bullying towards LDS
feminists when he was stake president
but he also did his homework with more
than a few Mormon women so traced
Romney's changing attitudes to be sure
Romney never embraced feminism and still
had tensions with some women but he was
able to build bridges with them in a
pragmatic problem-solving way the writer
seems to understand some of the dynamics
at play between a young bishop a stake
president and the women in his blog I
did wonder about this paragraph though
quote as Bishop Romney exercised great
power over his congregation besides
appointing staff members from the local
church librarian or librarian to choir
master he interviewed people in the
congregation to determine their fealty
to the church yeah that's great power he
decided who would carry a quote
recommend a physical card that serves as
proof of a person's good doctrinal
standing and soot soot ability to enter
a sacred temples again nothing factually
wrong with that paragraph but it implies
the kind of unnatural power that can or
cannot be there I have no doubt that
Romney was a strong bishop but this
seems to overstate the sense of his
empowerment and under plays the role of
a three-member bishopric in the issuing
of temple recommends The Times goodstein
has written thoughtfully and thoroughly
about the theological differences
between Mormons and evangelical
Christians the church's ad campaign and
just yesterday about how Romney's
position on immigration is more
conservative than his churches a story I
intended to write before this on the eve
of the florida republican primary
kathleen Grossman from USA
today I wrote a complicated and
comprehensive analysis about why
evangelicals are still wearing Mormons
it was well done and fair only one error
she said gordon b hinckley rather than
Spencer Kimball into the priesthood ban
but those kinds of mistakes can happen
to anyone even the best reporters
however will never fully grass Mormonism
until they get past the Protestant point
of view the American worth born faith as
many scholars in this room have noted is
really a new religious tradition though
it borrowed ideas and practices and
traditions from any other face it really
has no easy analogue to explain
Mormonism requires finding reasoned
guides both within it and Outsiders like
Jan ship Sally Gordon and max Mueller
who are available as sources the more
the better I say it is also going to
take more than I am a Mormon I'm a
Mormon for reporters to realize that
Mormonism is more multi-layered and
diverse than they thought for its part
the LDS Church itself needs to do a
better job of explaining its history
theology and practices and pointing
reporters to writers academics and
influential members who can reporters
will not be persuaded when a male church
spokesman claims that all Mormon women
are happy with their roles in the church
just saying that Mormons are not weird
and putting a smile on their faces will
not end the weariness and suspicion by
outsiders no matter how nice Mormon seem
to their neighbors or how many values
they share with conservative
Christianity they are living on a
narrative unlike any other faith
complete with angels gold plates a
cross-country Trek new names apostles
yes food storage secret rituals and much
more journalists will never get it right
until they recognize the distinctions
such depth of understanding among
trained journalists will not stop the
hostile simplistic or bigoted opinion
pieces but it could improve the level of
discourse about Mormonism as it plays
out in this extraordinarily public time
thank you
you